pas brillant c'est pas la première fois
que vous dites que vous arrêtez tout et
finalement vous n'arrêtez pas par moi
j'ai énormément de respect pour vous
mais est ce que vous vous comportez pas
un peu comme une rock star à dire
j'arrête tout non vous faire supplier
par vos fans et revenir c'est un peu
tard non je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire moi je serai j'avais dit que
j'arrêtais pmp pas même chose mais vous
êtes revenu et je suis revenu parce
qu'on a posé de nouvelles règles qui
vont couvrir c'est aussi simple que ça
jeudi un boîtier pas là commencez pas
abattu on a une leçon d'égocentrisme
votre égocentrisme vous fait le show en
permanence avec quoi vous parlez
[Rires]
ya des gens derrière et qui
chercheraient ce qui se passe autour de
vous et puis aussi alors lundi j'allais
au départ c'est la madeleine du barroux
jalon dès lundi puis mardi annonce que
peut-être je reviens et attention
aujourd'hui annonce il n'annonce que
demain il donnera ses comptes
ces conditions il n'est pas dit non mais
ça va saigner alors ça c'est génial
parce qu'en fait c'est débile
c'est bien c'est génial de voir qu'ils
se ridiculisent comme ça parce que pour
le coup quentinois moi ce que je suis en
train de vous dire j'étais à ce gentil
monsieur à côté moi c'est ça c'était un
moment donné quand vous faites des mots
et des vous fais défoncer par l'express
wen a défoncé pour des menaces de mort à
mayence est arrivé à abandonner paris
vous dites ok non je sais qu'il a pris
beaucoup de trucs dans la gueule en
permanence et qui est marrant c'est
qu'ils se mettent tout en scène pour on
va dire parce qu'on se met en scène
savamment sont des menaces de mort mais
c'est
ce que je dis c'est que le jdd sort des
accusations ça se passe est vrai ou faux
j'en sais rien mais vous quelques heures
grande gueule au moment où tout d'un
coup on commence à vous accusez non
plus ça n'a rien à voir n'importe quoi
il vous raconter n'importe quoi parce
qu'effectivement vous dites upp à
l'année dernière et que vous connaissez
pas alors de grâce évitez d'un côté
n'importe quoi est ce que concrètement
effectivement le problème qui se pose
depuis un an en tout cas depuis quelques
mois maintenant c'est que nous avons une
hystérisation j'en conviens que c'est
les règles du jeu et que j'ai sans doute
contribué à la différence c'est que j'ai
mené à ces personnes pour ce qui me
concerne à la différence c'est que j'ai
pas envoyer de mails de menaces de mort
pour ce qui me concerne c'est ça la
différence à la différence c'est que
j'ai pas allez je vais pas aller
effectivement sortir les poubelles des
années alors tant mieux si vous êtes
habitués moi non et je suis désolé
d'avoir encore du mal à m'y habituer
alors passer à la dernière partie de
l'émission merci oui je suis allé en
retrait de la vie publique mais
apparemment vous et moi vente mois et
demi avant de retomber dessus d'abord
bien ne faudrait pas non d'accord ce que
vous dites jeudi qu' apparemment il
avait mis en vente sur les listes de
jockey à mettre en venté et ses séries
pas de voiture au bout du compte la
question
abri c'est un dossier sur lequel vous
n'êtes pas clair du tout c'est ce qui
concerne le barreau de paris vos
collègues avocats parce que vous dites
j'ai la preuve j'ai la preuve que le
conseil de l'or n'a pas diligenté une
enquête contre moi oui mais selon mes
informations il ya un examen approfondi
s'est passé au drame
et répondez moi mais c'est un examen
approfondi des affaires qui est en cours
et alors d'accord ces trois ans confirmé
d'abord première chose dont je ne
confirme rien selon vos informations
elles sont sur france info génial les
infos
examen 110 kg dit alors huit mois
fabrice ferrier est ce qu'il ya et
qu'est ce qui avait conduit et qu'est ce
que ça vaut pas pour garder mais savez
vous répondez pas à la question y avait
danger non je n'en sais bien approfondie
ce cas je n'en sais rien je vous ai
rythme à moi c'est que oui baveux à bas
loyer il fait que oui donc il balance
le mec il est 20 heures ils balancent au
public que l'objet d'une enquête selon l
examen approfondi mais jamais pour les
commentateurs ils ont des idées et
comment voulez vous je veux défendre
face à ça et ben si vous montez passe
connais pas leurs efforts
fabrice il ya pas mal de gens qui posent
cette question est-ce que vous assumez
d'avoir comparé le pass annie terre un
viol en disant vous avez 16 18 ans vous
êtes en relation avec quelqu'un un jour
il va vous dire âge à 60 ans au moment
de l'autorisation oui c'est d'abord que
je veux un acte sexuel c'est pour qu'il
assume tout le pognon mais j'assume
complètement
stérile mais attendez attendez cependant
pas raison qui est en jeu dit elle
permet la comparaison elle nous bat
raison est ce qu'elle est les gallois ce
qu'elle n'est pas
attendez
des matches est-ce qu'on a nous a donnés
par comparaison la grippe a vous savez
très bien qu'en disant ça il ya des
femmes qui nous regardons des hommes
peut-être qu'ils ont été violés et
qu'ils vont dans leur chair ne pas
supporter ce que vous venez de dire est
emparé apa sanitaire qui est ce qu'il ya
une vocation dont la der on n'adhère pas
mais la vocation du passage et essaie de
protéger les gens sans dire où le chef
de protéger
je dis que je dis qu'effectivement en
philosophie morale
les choses sont très claires ce que je
fais c'est de la philosophie morale et
que moi j'y peux absolument rien si vous
avez choisi de déporter le débat sur le
terrain de l'émotion en permanence et
j'avais sur le terrain de la real et que
si on doit se limiter à chaque fois son
entreprise de parole en se disant mais
comment est-ce que mon propos va être
accueilli par l'autre sur le plan
émotionnel et le ciel
sera de retour certainement mardi pour
fixer les règles du jeu vous les
connaissez avant parce qu'ils les
annonces de mannequins noirs desseins
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai raté me choque un mec qui quand
même bien ils ont quand même c'est que
quand même finalement on est capable de
raconter des débilités
shirani vous savez je suis apte à un
petit peloton que l'année dernière oui
en l'occurrence que je veux dire ici
aujourd'hui c'est que ce mépris dans
lequel vous m'étonnez et bien tout à
l'heure par l'ailier cette comparaison
est là qu est ce qui fait depuis tout à
l'heure qu'est ce qui fait finalement de
puteaux l'heure sinon distiller le
mépris c'est ça la vérité mais rend con
ex collée dessus du terrain je termine
toutefois on explique juste que
fondamentalement est quand même en
donner une pression absolument je dois
m'en sur abl je suis dit et on a
quelqu'un qui se fout de ma gueule
pardon
est-ce qu'il se trouve drôle vraiment
jolie comme tout on s'excuse et mon
physique se trouvent des hommes mais
c'est un problème mais voilà alors mal
rires la souffrance des autres c'est
toujours un problème alors ça vous
grandit pas tellement et vous êtes déjà
pas très grand
[Applaudissements]
mais le vrai problème la journée si on
est sérieux deux minutes le vrai
problème justement c'est que c'est un
sujet sérieux et que ce monsieur
tournent tous autour de lui donner sa
réponse et vous facile on voit mal genre
en permanence autour de sujets alors
vous ne passez pas un bruit pas à côté
de ça les met les mains même si c'est un
sujet sérieux arrêtez d'en parler
[Applaudissements]